تداعيات قراري بكين بتسهيل اجراءات السفر
منها واليها تتوالى الولايات المتحده اخر
المنضمين لقائمه الدول التي تفرض الزاميه
اجراء اختبارات فيروس كورونا على زوارها
من الصين وزاره الصحه الامريكيه وضعت
شروطا لاجراءتها من بينها ان يكون لاختبار
قبل يومين على الاقل من السفر وان يشمل
الاختبار الركاب الذين يقومون برحلات ربط
عبر امريكا والى دول اخرى الى جانب
المسافرين عبر دوله ثالثه المسار الامريكي
تجاه قرارات الصين الاخيره سبقتها فيه كل
من ايطاليا واليابان والهند وتايوان
وماليزيا قرارات وكبها تحرك من الاتحاد
الاوروبي الذي قرر عدم اتباع خطى ايطاليا
وامريكا في تشديد القيود على القادمين من
الصين الى جانب وصفه وكاله الامراض
الاوروبيه لتلك القرارات بغير المباراه
ووفقا لاحصاء اخير ابلغت بكين عن نحو 4000
اصابه جديده بكرونا يوم 23 من ديسمبر
الماضي قبل ان تتوقف وزاره الصحه عن نشر
ارقام الحالات اليوميه لكن شركه البيانات
الصحيه البريطانيه انفنتي قدرت ان الصين
تشهد اكثر من مليون اصابه وخمسه الاف حاله
وفاه في اليوم وفقا لوكاله رويترز
اوضاع الصحيه في الصين وترحيب من الداخل
من قبل المواطنين الراغبين في السفر بعد
ما يقرب من ثلاث سنوات من القيود الصارمه
ضمن السياسه صفر كوفد التي وجهت باحتجاجات
شعبيه ثم قرار باعاده فتح الحدود مره اخرى
بدءا من الاسبوع المقبل
علي السمان العربيه